or c'est une famille cette famille
maison un problème c'est que les enfants
qui grandissent et leurs problèmes ses
trois frères et quand ils ont entre 10
et 15 ans et là les parents le pépin
c'est que maintenant ils sont obligés de
trouver des défuntes pour aller faire
l'amour quoi et donc ils montrent un
plan ils disent 'voilà ce soir quand
qu'on va manger voilà quand je vais
servir la soupe chérie je vais faire
exprès de tout renverser sur la chemise
comme ça toi tu vas partiront pour aller
de changer et moi comme je sais où sont
tes chemise je vais te rejoindre
ils montrent leur plomb c'est parti le
soir arrive le repas la mer et sert la
soupe au premier au deuxième au
troisième enfant et arrive au père push
et à lui pourrir sa chemise
le père a fait semblant de viol et voilà
ma chemise maire de regarde au point de
faire bas la junte après tu encore
d'accord qu'on avait gagné leur donne
évidemment c'est donc tu manques se
changer la mère dit aux enfants à la
lame et votre père il sait pas où sont
les chemises je vais le rejoindre je
vais l'aider
et donc là les deux arrivent dans la
chambre en sa part sept chars nadal
qu'ils enlèvent tout la mer sur le
lavabo le père bam bam
mais entre temps il ya un petit hic est
monté et voit la scène
donc il redescendra ses frères idiots
les frérots renversé par votre soupe
parce que papa il va vous faire un truc
de fou
aller très bien oui bon ça se passe dans
une classe la maîtresse elle vit classe
de ce2 demain voilà pour le l'exposé sur
la médecine du travail et sur les
métiers demain ramener chacun amène un
truc de chez lui qui soigne les gens
ok donc le lendemain à la petite et
minières a ramené du doliprane hadj
assez bien nourri le doliprane
ça sert à soigner les gens qui ont mal à
la tête adia ça c'est très bien elle
tout un cas médical
moi j'ai ramené du mercurochrome indien
pas si c'est bien ça soigne les gens qui
se blesse et beit pas sébastien dia moi
j'ai ramené tous trop de bouteilles
d'oxygène de mamie ad c'est bien mais ta
mamie elle t'a laissé didier pas me
piquer
[Applaudissements]
c'est un mec il est beau mais comme
l'expliqué me superbe au genre à m sila
quoi ouais à médecine a beau gosse de
ouf tu vois que j'en dis pas un problème
donc ces femmes est présenti pour les
autres ils sont tous beaux on côté là un
problème à chaque fois qu'il pallie fait
chaque fois qu'il va draguer pas tu te
fais de mal que de l'après midi tu es
libre
donc il n'y a pas une même qu'il met à
jouer tu tombe sur une fille elle lui
dit écoute moi ton problème ça ne
dérange pas par contre faut que tu le
soignent si tu veux qu'on se marie le
dit mais comment tu cros marie tous les
deux c'est très bien de ce problème là
ça s'enlève pas le dénommé t'inquiète
pas ça m'a enlevé il ya une clinique qui
vient d'ouvrir justement pour les gens
qui ont été comme ça et tu t'inquiètes
pas tous qui va dire qu'il dit qui doit
rester un mois dans votre ligne d'eau
qui vivent à il a créé par l'infirmière
la fermière à lui dire bonjour oui j'ai
un gros problème
ouais vous inquiétez pas ici pendant
vous soigner vous êtes sûr que oui
sacré bordel inquiétez pas le docteur va
vous recevoir rennes docteur là j'ai dit
ça qu'il allait rentrer monsieur et
attendez moi je peux pas aller jour ou
si vous avez un problème aux bambous
guéret
qui rêve pendant un mois il est dans la
clinique il sort de la clinique 1 mois 1
il vient voir pour demander blâme à la
main de sa copine assez pas ou pas on la
copie n'est les toits cibona star moins
aguerris d'y alors vous voulez ma fille
et du crous
oui
[Applaudissements]
son style